america's epidemic of addiction and how
the coronavirus pandemic helped make it
deadlier than ever today we learned that
more than a hundred thousand americans
died of drug overdoses in the last year
that is the highest overdose death toll
ever recorded in a 12-month period the
u.s centers for disease control and
prevention said a hundred thousand three
hundred americans
died of overdoses between may of 2020
and april of 2021. that is a 28 percent
increase on the previous year most of
the deaths came from overdoses of the
synthetic drug fentanyl an epidemic of
addiction made worse by the cobit 19
pandemic lockdowns left drug users
socially isolated unable to get
treatment
drug overdoses now claim more lives than
car accidents and gun violence in
america combined
and this is truly and tragically a
uniquely american story a comparison
with countries here in europe shows how
dramatic the difference is in the these
figures are germany has 1.7 deaths
per 100 000. we were talking about
overdose
norway has the highest total here in
europe five per one hundred thousand the
figure for the united states is four
times that at 21.1 per 100 000.
yeah big difference and for more tonight
i'm joined by keith humphries he's a
professor of psychiatry and behavioral
sciences at stanford university
professor it's good to have you on the
program
the
opioid epidemic existed long before the
coronavirus pandemic began
as they began running parallel in the
united states
there should have been a completely
different response
how do you explain
so many preventable deaths in the u.s
well i mean we had a terrible problem in
the united states and i have to say in
canada as well which also has an opioid
epidemic of unrestrained prescribing
which went on for about 15 years of
drugs like oxycontin and increased our
exposure to those drugs by about 400
percent in a short time and then once a
large number of people were addicted
then there were opportunities for people
who make drugs like heroin and fentanyl
to
expand their business and now a lot of
those users have transitioned over so we
are still losing some people to
prescription medications but mostly as
you said in your setup piece the deaths
are illicit drugs like fentanyl so it's
been a long uh a long horrible road for
us and i'm afraid there's just a lot
more to travel
and the region's hardest hit
are also places where we find the most
people who do not have health
insurance
politics and policies leading the poor
to take pills that kill them
do you agree with that is that an
accurate assessment of what's going on
it's absolutely the case that
these deaths are disproportionately
concentrated
in in areas where there's been
de-industrialization
where a lot of people do not have work
or have only low paying work and that is
part of the picture that has brought us
to this point but it certainly isn't all
of it it's also an incredible increase
in the supply beyond what has ever any
society has ever had before and those
two things together were deadly
combination for many americans
and
is that what explains america's overdose
epidemic dwarfing what we see here in
europe is it the supply issue
well we we certainly had far more supply
from the legal medication market us and
canada by the way which also has
epidemics so about that or interesting
increase
you do see something close to it in uh
scotland uh which has a more coming from
the illicit inherent supply but
it's we never never had as much exposure
in europe through the prescription
system also you know everybody in europe
has health insurance not everyone in
america does so there's people who want
treatment and can't get it that
exacerbates the the harm of being
addicted it's far more likely that
you'll
die um and also part of it's
geographical we are a very big country
we have a lot of people who live far
from hospitals far from help and if they
have an overdose it's harder for us to
help them that would be in a you know
geographically compact country yeah we
were talking in the newsroom earlier
today about this and wondering why the
differences are so stark and
in the united states it seems that if
there's something wrong with you the
first reaction is to go to the doctor
and ask for a prescription a pill to fix
it
here in germany it's almost you get the
feeling that doctors are very reluctant
to prescribe anything even especially
when you have pain
is is there a an attitudinal difference
when it comes to treating
pain
with a pill
yeah in fact germany is a very good
country to contrast it it has a high
rate per capita of using opioids but
they're used almost entirely
in hospitals and in nursing homes with a
high degree of monitoring what differs
over here is a huge number of people are
sent out from doctors offices with
prescriptions um on their own and that
easily many of those make their way into
society more generally sometimes the
person takes them sometimes they don't
sometimes they are taken by somebody
else sometimes they are sold and that's
probably part of the problem and you
also hit on the cultural thing which is
true is that there's an expectation of a
lot of patients in the united states
that all problems are fixable
and
and that sometimes they pressure
providers to write pills not just for
opioids for everything um you know and
and we have ads on tv uh here which uh
is not the case in europe telling people
no matter what your problems are there's
a pill for them ask your doctor about
that pill and that probably increases
the amount of prescriptions that we send
out in the world and also the harms of
those prescriptions you also see
professor on the prescription medication
advertised on television in the united
states which you do not see here in
germany if you were to maybe go in the
u.s change that do you think that it
would change the way people look at
medication
yeah we are there's only two countries
on earth it's united states and new
zealand that allow prescription
medication to be marketed directly to
consumers and i think it's a bad thing
in that it does convey that message of
there is a pill for everything and you
should be taking it and ask your doctor
about it and you know i could never
prove that it's not like we can randomly
assign countries to um advertising
campaigns but i i personally think that
is part of the the problem of looking to
pills for everything including to solve
deep structural problems in the economy
for example or in society
that really need to be managed at a
different level than patient by patient
keith humphreys professor of psychiatry
and behavioral sciences at stanford
university professor we appreciate your
time and your valuable insights tonight
thank you
thank you